it is seven o'clock good to see you and
we begin this morning with breaking news
on the cost of living the UK's latest
inflation figures are due to be
published well right now they'll be
telling us how much more we have to pay
for everything from the cost of driving
home for Christmas the food for the
table I'll even those gifts for your
loved ones it is Wednesday the 14th of
December
okay where Traders will be absorbing the
latest inflation figure we just have
inflation running at 10.7 percent
Seeking Justice for war crimes Sky News
discovers how the UK is training
Ukrainian judges to prosecute Russian
soldiers
they are Prosecuting war crimes in real
time this is a live and very brutal
conflict
the government's emergency committee
meets this morning with real unions and
postal workers on strike nurses well
they're due to work out tomorrow
a major incident is declared on Shetland
where snow has brought down power lines
and thousands of homes are expected to
be cut off for days
or England's cricket captain Freddie
flintoff is airlifted to hospital after
a crash on the set of Top Gear
[Music]
at morning all and we begin with that
breaking news on the economy the latest
uh inflation figures for November have
just been published you might want to
look away now their inflation currently
running at 10.7 let's bring in our
business correspondent Paul Kelso
joining us from birmingham's wholesale
Market Paul good morning to you um I
mean eye-watering to put it mildly
it is an eye watering figure almost as
eye watering as the temperatures here
this morning the Traders here earning
their money this week in these
temperatures but amazingly that figure
10.7 up near 40 years highs is actually
a little glimmer of good news it's off
the peak we saw one maybe the peak of
inflation in the last monthly figures of
11.1 certainly everybody here and around
the country will be hoping this does
signify we've hit the top of the
inflationary curve 10.7 of course still
a huge amount to bear on the cost of
living but trade is here saying already
they are seats starting to see a little
bit of an impact in a small reduction in
prices they put that down to fuel prices
easing slightly and that could be
passing on through to customers this
place serves the restaurants and shops
of Birmingham and the West Midlands so
the produce bought here the price paid
in this market feeds right the way
through the local economy into the
prices people paying are paying in the
shots of course this stumble we watched
very keenly also in Westminster this is
incredibly High inflation the backdrop
fueling the industrial action we've seen
over the last two months intensifying
over this Christmas period yesterday we
sort of heard that wages were Rising uh
only four percent in real terms way
below the real cost of inflation at 10.7
that number isn't going to change
dramatically and this can simply perhaps
going to entrench the views of those on
the receiving end of these Rising costs
the workers who are demonstrating and
taking industrial action for higher pay
against the government that seems at the
moment more intent on offsetting the
impact of strikes than working to end
them but here Traders just sensing a
little bit of good news in these prices
rising still very high but not as high
as last month I apologize as you say
those industrial disputes ongoing
negotiations such as they are at not yet
completed with inflation running you
know ahead away from 11 does it
strengthen or weaken the government's
case that to give you know huge sway to
the public sector significant pay rises
above the three four percent that some
are talking about right now that that
would be inflationary in and of itself
does it does this weaken or strengthen
their case
uh I'm yet to check what the reaction is
from the chance of the exchequer we will
get one uh very promptly this morning
but I imagine that will be precisely his
argument with inflation running so high
to fuel to to add High pay uh what they
would see is high pay settlements in the
public sector would further fuel that
inflation would fuel what is known as a
wage price spiral that is as prices rise
wages Rises to keep up that entrenches
high prices there is a strong argument
though that's made on the public sector
side of this that there's no cost to the
economy of paying public sector workers
more they will spend that money in the
economy but there are no goods and
services that are getting more expensive
because you're paying nurses more or
paying teachers more in fact you may be
feeding some of that money back into the
tax system in due course and remember
wages are not as high as inflation a
classic wage price spiral is when wages
are at or exceeding inflation at the
moment they are well behind that rate of
inflation I'm sure the counter argument
from the unions will be that people
simply need enough pay to keep up with
prices and of course certainly in the
public sector we're seeing the compound
impact of a decade of austerity real
wages way below where they were they
haven't kept up within inflation but
that argument is at the heart of these
industrial disputes and I suspect we
will see in the coming days those
positions entrenching rather than being
eased by the fact that inflation may
just may have reached its peak I suspect
you might have a point much more from
you throughout the morning Paul I know
that's very much indeed but we do indeed
have immediate reaction to those figures
from Labor uh Rachel Reeves Labor's
Shadow chancellor has said this the
question people across Britain will be
asking themselves this morning is do I
and my family feel better off under the
Tories the answer will be no Libra's
ritual weaves continues at today's
numbers show just how weak our economy
continues to be but we do not have to
continue on this path of managed decline
we will be speaking to laborers Emily
Thornbury in the next hour but let's
turn our attention to Ukraine and the
center of Kiev has been hit by air
strikes during the night it is currently
unclear whether anyone has been killed
or indeed injured but the city mayor
says that the emergency services are on
the scene eventually Ukraine will be
Seeking Justice for the victims of
Russian aggression Sky News has learned
that the UK is providing training for 90
Ukrainian judges to help them prosecute
war crimes our political correspondent
Tamara Cohen has this exclusive report
horrors of the Ukraine war are still
raging and maybe for months or years to
come but bringing the perpetrators of
war crimes to Justice doesn't need to
wait
the government's top lawyer told me
about the Intensive training the UK is
giving to 90 Ukrainian judges at a
secret location in the region to help
them convict Russian soldiers they are
Prosecuting war crimes in real time this
is a live and very brutal conflict I
hope that those Russian soldiers and
officers who are watching the Ukrainian
prosecutions at the moment will realize
that they must act in accordance with
international law most war crimes will
be tried in Ukraine but its president is
also pushing for an international
tribunal modeled on the Nuremberg trials
the aim is to have prosecutions at all
levels isn't it the rank and file
soldiers but also the Russian top
generals and maybe one day Vladimir
Putin the International Community will
want to have a moment where Justice is
done and seen to be done we don't yet
know exactly what form that will take I
I don't think when I was a government
lawyer that we ever anticipated that we
would have war crimes in Europe in the
way that that we did
um again in the second world war and
that we would have to start talking
about Nuremberg style trials Sky News
teams have witnessed the sort of
atrocities for which it is hoped Russian
leaders will eventually be held
accountable
like these killings in macarieve on the
outskirts of Kiev where officials say
over 130 bodies were found they've never
tried war crimes before and it's a
specialized business sir Howard Morrison
a former judge at the international
criminal court in The Hague spoke to us
after his first session with the
Ukrainian judges
25 years staring either literally or
metaphorically into Mass Graves and
believe you me it's a very different
exercise than a single body or a single
victim so far Ukrainian authorities have
convicted 14 Russian soldiers the number
of cases recorded is more than 43 000.
the ball is rolling but it will take
time money and political will to reach
the bigger targets
and Tamara joins us in the studio good
to see you this morning um I wonder how
this will play into the the request from
Vladimir zielinski and his wife when she
was here in this country that there will
at some point be some kind of Nuremberg
style set of Trials because as things
stand it is just the ukrainians that are
Prosecuting these crimes currently
that's right and most of them will be
done in Ukraine through Ukrainian courts
which is why they're getting this help
to make sure they reach the right
International standards because um they
have not done this at scale before under
the condition of hostility still going
on because previous war crimes trials
have been done in general afterwards and
this idea of a special tribunal yes it
is really Gathering Pace now the there
is going to be an international criminal
court investigation it's going on
already and all countries are backing
that but the ukrainians say that the
crime of aggression as in the actual
Invasion and blaming Russian leaders
needs to be done separately and just in
the last couple of weeks the French
government are now supporting that the
European commission president to live
under lion is supporting it too Victoria
Prentice said it's on the table we're
not ruling it out and she wants to keep
discussing the idea but it felt like the
British government is now inching
towards it as well obviously will take
some time to set up but the idea that
Russian leaders of course you can get
hold of them might eventually be put on
trial that kind of special tribunal does
seem to be gathering more support it
doesn't indeed tomato thank you very
much indeed but let's just take you back
to the breaking news on inflation those
figures published in the last few
minutes showing that prices rise at
prices have risen I should say by 10.7
in November we have been hearing from
the chancellor of the exchecker Jeremy
Hunt is what he has to say the
aftershocks of covid-19 and Putin's
weaponization of gas mean that high
inflation is plaguing economies across
Europe uh the chancellor continues that
he knows families and businesses are
struggling here in the UK getting
inflation down says Mr Hunt uh so
people's wages go further is my top
priority which is why we are holding
down energy bills this winter through
our energy price guarantee scheme and
implementing a plan to help have
inflation next year Mr Hunt continues in
the statement so I know it is tough for
many right now but it is vital that we
take tough decisions needed to tackle
inflation the number one enemy that
makes everyone poorer Mr Hunt concludes
if we make the wrong choices now high
prices will persist and prolong the pain
for Millions
let's turn our attention to shetlands
what a major incident has been declared
after thousands of homes were left
without power following heavy snow which
brought down power lines let's speak to
our Scotland correspondent Connor Gillis
who joins us now Connor I mean Shetland
at the best of times you know it's a
pretty extreme and exposed place but
without power at this time of year it's
going to be grim
Graham indeed that is the situation
facing so many people in the northern
Isles as you said they are vulnerable to
the extreme weather at the best of times
but even Engineers on uh Shetland are
saying they have seen nothing like this
in the last 20 years that puts it in
context at just how bad a situation at
locals there are facing as you said the
problems uh relate back to that snow and
ice uh falling on those overhead power
cables they have been weighing those
down and then eventually snapping them
and causing all sorts of uh problems
Shetland has a population the islands of
Shetland have a population of around 22
000 and to put it again in further
context at this morning SSE and the
distribution energy Network have told me
that it's at 2 800 properties remain
without power at this stage also this is
a part of the world with no access to
Maine's gas supply that many people on
the mainland across the whole of the UK
enjoy so that adds to that further
Reliance on the electricity Network now
Community hubs have been set up across
the islands to try and help people with
gas stoves and making food in that
Community effort of people rallying
together has been coming together in
recent days but of course the efforts to
try and help people have been hampered
by this extreme weather because it's not
just the mainland of Shetland this is an
island with various islands off uh its
Coast as well now the rescue effort has
been increasingly difficult because the
Island's airport has been closed which
has meant that Engineers have had to get
that long Ferry Journey up there to try
and assist with those efforts I'm told
this morning that 15 Crews will be
arriving on that first ferry the airport
has now reopened an ssen distribution
networks is looking to try and fly
helicopters to and from from Shetland to
speed up the process but locals are
being told that it is likely to be
Thursday at the earliest that they will
be reconnected some may be waiting into
the weekend we're also hearing as well
that uh women's body has been found in
an outbuilding in the very north of the
Mainland of Shetland the Coast Guard
rescue helicopter was part of that major
effort in the last 24 hours police
Scotland not ruling out at this stage
that weather may have played a part in
that lady's death we're waiting for that
confirmation from police Scotland in the
meantime a major incident has been
declared by the Scottish government and
the local Council on the islands who are
asking people to remain indoors at this
critical time I mean Connor what is the
weather forecast for the next few days
there
so the weather forecast is looking like
an improving picture the issue has been
uh to try and get people to get those
Engineers to the island
um it can be a very difficult task
because that airport has not been opened
so yes the weather conditions have been
improving but it is a slow journey to
try and reconnect those islands because
people are so spread out across that
part of the world Connor many thanks
indeed
oh let's stick with the severe weather
uh Skies uh summer Chaudhary uh joining
us now uh Saba just tell us bring us a
little bit up to date I mean it's it's
been pretty Grim it's been pretty
extreme you you look wrapped up you
actually you look all right to be
perfectly honest with you I was
expecting to see Willie Bonnet and scarf
on
good morning arrive come well prepared
I'm I'm well well layered Neil this
morning it's minus one degrees here in
central London and uh Bremer and
aberdeenshire it's minus 17.3 degrees
Celsius so it could be worse
um but uh I'm here in central London and
I'm joined by uh Petra Salvo who is from
Saint mongers they're a homeless charity
and the reason we're here with them
today is to really get a picture of what
it's like for people who have to live
rough on the streets this time of year
now Petra thank you for joining us on
Sky News living uh being homeless is
difficult any time of the year but at
this particular juncture it can cost
lives now tell me a little bit about
what saint mungo's are doing to help
those living rough yeah you're
absolutely right I mean sleeping rough
is dangerous every night of the year but
as temperatures plummet it becomes more
life-threatening so mongos they're a
leading homelessness charity we work
across you know 365 days of the year but
when it gets really cold our teams are
out 24 7 trying to get people out of the
cold and out of the danger and into
places of safety so our teams are
working now they're working right now
and they've helped hundreds of people
off the streets already across London
across the southeast we're really
concerned about people's welfare all the
time but right now it is
life-threatening and tell me
specifically about some of the the
Outreach work that you guys are doing uh
today yeah so the teams go out in pairs
they they're literally looking for
people who are better down I just walked
here today we're in central London I was
concerned I saw people under blankets so
my teams they're resilient Lots they
literally go up to people they offer
them help and when they're really
concerned they you know sometimes we
find that people are in desperate need
of medical assistance because they
didn't realize themselves how cold it
was so this is really life-threatening
stuff I mean I'm not not seen cold
temperatures like this for a long time
and for such a prolonged period of time
so our teams are literally saving lives
Petra thank you so much so a difficult
time indeed especially for those
currently in the cold but good work
being done by the likes of Saint mongos
to help those that need it yeah
fantastic work Saba many thanks indeed
but let's give you some of the day's
other headlines now and the former
England cricket star Andrew Freddie
flintoff has been taken to hospital
following an accident during the filming
of an episode of Top Gear the BBC says
the presenter was injured on a test
track in Surrey
in a statement they said this Freddie
was injured in an accident at the Top
Gear test track this morning with crew
Medics attending the scene immediately
he has been taken to hospital for
further treatment and we will confirm
more details in due course
and South Devon has been forced to close
due to an outbreak of strep a
Kingsbridge Community primary school
shot on Tuesday with 40 of pupils and 23
of Staff of sick
The Prince and Princess of Wales have
released a new family photograph for
their annual Christmas cards it shows
the royal couple alongside their three
children Prince George princess
Charlotte and Prince Louis are working
together earlier this year in Norfolk
yeah that wasn't a recent photo
I had time now for a quick look at the
morning's papers and as you'd expect
that picture is on lots of the front
pages you can see it there at the top of
the front page of the mail its main
headline however quoting the Prime
Minister saying he will fix the
appalling Asylum farce
the Metro reports on the prime
minister's pledge to clear the Asylum
backlog within a year
and the telegraph also leading with the
Promises by Mr sunac saying he'll Stop
Those Who quotes got here by cheating
the express chooses to lead on the
strikes the paper has a plea can we have
our country back please
and the times has the UK's Chief nurses
telling the heads of the nurses Union
that key Services could be in Jeopardy
uh when if they walk out tomorrow
and the mirrors headline nurses say we
are doing this for you
now China has announced it will stop
reporting new asymptomatic covert
infections the latest step in the
country's move away from their zero
covert policy of Asia correspondent
Helen Ann Smith joins us now live from
Beijing um Helen explain exactly the
rationale behind all of this I
understand why given the protest that we
saw that people were wishing uh the
government to move away from the zero
covered policy but how does this play
into that
foreign
well it sounds very technical doesn't it
Neil but it's actually extremely
significant because what it really means
is that the major wave of covert
infection spreading across this country
will not be properly tracked and people
will never really know just how bad it
is just to quickly explain China have
throughout the pandemic been separating
asymptomatic from symptomatic cases and
that the definition of which falls into
which category has often been a little
unclear but broadly asymptomatic cases
have made up the very vast majority of
daily infections so taking those out of
the accounting essentially mean the
official numbers will absolutely plummet
and no one will have any real idea
exactly how serious this outbreak
actually is and I cannot emphasize
enough just how major the outbreak of
covert does seem to be particularly in
the city of Beijing just anecdotally you
know everybody we know has it it really
is an incredible outbreak of this
disease and that's currently sort of
underway in the city so why well the
authorities say it's because people
aren't participating in the tests
anymore and as you can see this testing
boost behind me I mean the queues used
to be huge at this testing booth there
was just a tiny trickle of people so
there is a degree to which that is true
but there's also a sense that a lot of
this testing system has slightly
collapsed just for example I've had
multiple tests at booths like this in
the last week I've only had one result
back so a sense the testing system isn't
working but accusations too that the
government might be trying to obscure
what's happening there is a massive wave
here following a sudden and dramatic
U-turn just take over deaths for example
there have been about a million
infections in this country since the
first of November only six deaths
reported so really a sense that it's not
clear exactly what's going on but the
Chinese people will start noticing if
the hospitals if the morgues if the
crematoriums become overrun in the weeks
to come
Helena many thanks
uh still to come on the program this
morning uh well as we've discovered the
UK is helping to train Ukrainian judges
to prosecute Russian war crimes I will
be speaking to one Ukrainian MP about
the fight for justice that's coming up
in just a second
with a major incident declared in
Shetland after thousands of homes were
left without power I'll be speaking to
the Island's Police Chief Inspector
[Music]
the shadow attorney general Emily
Thornbury will be here to discuss the
latest inflation figures the strikes
taking place and indeed that Ukrainian
scheme
uh to which we turn our attention no Sky
News has learned that the UK is
providing training for 90 Ukrainian
judges to prosecute war crimes but
putting criminals on trial while award
is still raging will prove to be
difficult tomorrow of course her story
so she's going to join me for this one
but also joining us now from Keith is
the Ukrainian MP Andre assadship Andre
lovely to see you this morning
um I understand though first and
foremost that you're in cave this
morning
um I'm just wondering how things have
been there reports of again significant
drone strike uh by the Russians do you
know much how has it been for you
good morning thank you very much indeed
having me here yes today morning there
were another Uh Russian Iranian
chemicals drone attack uh at 6 30 it was
uh pretty much loud uh even here in the
downtown for the moment the officials
report that two team chemicals and
drones has been shut down in the key of
sky today morning just I think 10-15
minutes ago the irates rents were
switched off so this this attack is over
uh no much damage as as my understanding
for the cycle for the moment some
administrative buildings were hit just I
think three five kilometers from me
so he was fighting
good very pleased to hear that and of
course at the air raid sirens have been
switched off so Andre let us talk about
this scheme the UK government providing
money and assistance here to train up
Ukrainian judges to deal with what we
understand to be a plethora of war
crimes allegations what is the
significance of this for you because
quite clearly the ukrainians wish to
prosecute as many of these war crimes as
is possible whilst the conflict is
ongoing
look a few very important things from
the very beginning of this big war since
March myself and many other Ukrainian
politicians were promoting one very
simple and clear narrative
a big part of Ukrainian Victory is not
just defeating Russians on Ukrainian
soil but bringing into accountability
everyone who committed war crimes in
Ukraine because without Justice based on
international law it's important to
expect peaceful and comfortable future
for this very moment it's not my wish
it's a giant Consolidated view of G7
just two days ago G7 spread its latest
communique and let me quote there can be
no impunity for war crimes and other
atrocities we will call President Putin
and those responsible to account in
accordance with international law so
it's not my wish anymore it's not the
wish of president zielinski or all other
ukrainians that's the Consolidated
understanding of the west but the
challenge is not only to bring Russian
literacy to accountability but to bring
into accountability everyone who
committed work Brands and at the moment
I can report to you that Ukrainian
officials registered more than 70
000 crimes related to racial aggression
more than 50 000 work brands has been
detected by a Ukrainian law enforcement
all that require absolutely huge efforts
from
prosecutors from experts from
investigators and definitely it's a huge
task for Ukrainian Judiciary System and
for Ukrainian Georges because it's
understood for today that yes top
Russian leaders will brought into
prosecution through International
tribunal Court I hope so I recently came
back from Hague and international
criminal recordings 8 is working
extremely hard to have a good result
with this but all these thousands of
work Brands definitely will be
considered by Ukrainian ports well Ray
they are doing this so said that the
training of Ukrainian judges is
extremely important because no one in
this world has enough capabilities and
enough experience to proceed with such a
huge amount of war crimes finishing I
will repeat the same without Justice
they will be now peaceful future for all
of us but to reach that we need to
defeat Russians first too indeed Andre I
just want to hand over to Tamara Kohn
our political correspondent who's been
speaking to to the British attorney
general who's organizing this scheme
tomorrow hi Andrea you've your judges
have prosecuted I think about 14 war
criminals so far Russian low-level
soldiers and commanders how quickly do
you expect it to accelerate it's
obviously a huge task
uh yes you are absolutely right there
were already several uh final word
decisions of identified Russians who
committed to killing and rape in Ukraine
especially of all these cases I think
from here region
look if we are talking about
of thousands of work Brands it's
understood that it will take years but
we shall not afraid of amount of time
which we will have to spend I am as a
lawyer I understand that it takes a lot
of resources and a lot of time but if in
three five ten years we will complete
this job it will be very good there is
no any other options for all of us
I'm afraid we have to leave it there but
we hope the skin works out work
successfully uh Andrea said thanks very
much for your time thanks for your input
as well tomorrow and but we're going to
go back to the cold weather and I'm
afraid to say at that Arctic blast which
has dropped the temperatures it is set
to continue across the UK over the
coming days uh Skies meteorologist at
Joe Wheeler joins us now in our regular
uh whether whether people in their back
Gardens segment and Joe just tell us how
much longer are we going to have to put
up with this how much longer are we
going to be sending you out the back to
freeze for three minutes every hour
I tell you something it is absolutely
perishing this morning it really is
we've picked up a bit of a breeze which
of course is making the the cold weather
feel even colder that's going to be the
case across the country uh so not so
much mist and fog around still warnings
out for uh the far north eastern Parts
the South West uh parts of Northern
Ireland for ice this morning snow
showers still coming into parts of
Scotland down the east coast and we've
got some sleetiness for Devin and
Cornwall but elsewhere as I say the
missing Fox are clear lots of sunshine
but so cold as that uh wind picks up and
the wind's strongest in the far
Northeast the far south west now we are
going to see a change but not a very
quick one so temperatures last night
weren't actually as cold as they were
the previous night we've seen still
seeing about minus 12 but add the wind
to that and there's just absolutely
horrendous so the cold weather is going
to stay with us for the snow showers to
come further ice obviously until we get
to the weekend and then we start to see
some wet and windy weather working its
way up from the south west and of course
once we pick up that southerly wind
things will change and by the time we
get to Sunday we're looking at daytime
temperatures in double figures can you
believe it
I can't but thank you
appropriately enough at time for us to
take a very quick break coming up next
to you on breakfast we will be healing
from The Institute for fiscal studies as
the rate of inflation easies slightly a
small glimmer of hope from UK
[Music]
welcome back and let's head back to
those newly released inflation figures
showing prices rising by 10.7 last month
and let's speak to Max one research
Economist at The Institute for fiscal
studies here to talk about something
else which we will do in just a second
Max but but I wonder your your immediate
reaction to those figures I'd say it's
probably not the time to break out the
bump but break out the bunting but you
know a small glimmer of hope for the
economy
good morning yeah as you say 10.7 over
the last 12 months that compares to 11.1
over the proceeding 12 months and so
yeah I think that is glimmer of hope I
guess the hope is that inflation is
going to now start coming down but this
is only really one month and so yeah we
don't want to over interpret it too much
but the hope is that it's going to
reduce pressure on households but also
crucial Public Services like the NHS
which is where we are to be focusing the
rest of our discussion Max of course
just tell us a little bit about your
research because it's a lot of it is
pre-counter intuitives and it stems from
the fact that we are spending more on
the Health Service than ever before and
yet treating fewer patients you're gonna
have to explain this one to me yes so as
you say we're spending more on the NHS
than we were pre-pandemic the NHS also
actually has staffed and pre-pandemic
yet across lots of different types of
care the NHS is treating fewer patients
than it was and really we view this as a
kind of continued impact of covid
creating a number of different pressures
all of which are making it harder for
the NHS to treat patients
what is the the role perhaps of social
care in all of this whenever I speak to
to friends colleagues who are working in
the front line of their Health Service
one of the biggest problems that they
they always point to is and you hate to
use the word bed blocker because it's
not their fault but but ultimately
practically that is what it is if you
cannot get people out of hospital then
you can't get people in
absolutely I think this is one of the
things that's been raised and you just
from personal experience I've had a
grandparent who's been stuck in hospital
for about seven weeks and they've
discharged there is some evidence this
is going on and that it's harder to
discharge patients than it was last year
so I think that's part of the story but
it's only one part there are lots of
other things for example fewer beds
available for non-coded patients that
are also matter too
so does this mean we we almost are
forced back to the drawing board to put
the blueprints of the health services as
initially conceived and and have to
start tinkering because the the
situation is not going to be resolved
necessarily by by just more money is it
I I think that's true I think we're wide
with that there is a risk that the
impact of covid isn't just going to be
for the next year or two but he's going
to have a kind of persistent and
long-running effect on how much care or
how many patients the NHS can treat with
the same level of resources and I agree
I think that raises important fiscal
questions about how and what we want the
NHS to do
um well look Max I don't know if it's
you're going to your grandpa will wish
them very well in a speedy recovery
thanks very much for your time this
morning
uh no the government's emergency
committee is meeting again this morning
to discuss the wave of industrial action
across the country real workers and
postal workers they're both out today
Nurses of course are set to go on strike
in England Wales Northern Ireland
tomorrow for the first time ever uh
let's bring in our political
correspondent Mari Aurora who joins us
now and from outside the cabinet office
where at Cobra that rather Butch Macho
uh acronym that they use to describe the
emergency committee will be taking place
a little later I mean ultimately what
more can they do
well that's the question Neil isn't it
so the government are massively Keen to
portray an image to the public that
they've got a grip on these strikes that
they are doing everything they possibly
can to mitigate as much of the
disruption as possible although we know
that the government Oliver Dowden said
just this week is not going to be
possible to completely kind of mitigate
all of the disruption we're expecting to
see especially because there are
cross-sector strikes so it's nurses
strike tomorrow another day two of train
strikes today we've got postal strikes
we've got border four strikes so
realistically there's going to be
massive disruption so in this just
building right behind me that is where
that Cobra meeting that emergency
committee as you were saying is going to
be taking place today where it's going
to be chaired by Oliver Dowden the
chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster and
some of the kind of top government
officials to try and show and find a
plan of how to deal with these strikes
especially considering we're going to
have so many strikes all over the
country and Christmas time as well
businesses are already being affected in
the Christmas season a lot of negative
press for the government now the
government have been accused of not
really getting around the table
sufficiently or really you know with any
realistic offer for the unions unions
have been heavily critical of the
government so the question is as you say
what can the government do to show that
they are having a grip on this situation
and will the public believe them
many thanks let's stick with the World
Cup and uh defending Champions France of
course knocked out England in the
quarters look to avoid an upset against
Morocco this evening let's get a little
bit more on this from Sky Sports News
correspondent Tim Thornton who's in Doha
for us this morning good to see you Tim
look France are looking fantastic of
course but I wonder if you have any
words of council for a for a breakfast
news presenter not a million miles away
from you right now who might have a
tenor in Morocco to win the whole thing
yeah good morning well Morocco have been
fantastic in this tournament they've
been the surprise package and they've
had to do it the hard way to get through
to the semi-finals they played against
Belgium they played against Croatia
they've played against Portugal and
against Spain and they've only conceded
one goal and that was a known goal so
their record defensively has been
outstanding they're the team that
everybody out here now has adopted is
their their second team they've got huge
support out here they've got a
goalkeeper who's been fantastic in Bono
he's been one of the standout performers
in this tournament so there are lots of
positives they'll have a huge fan base
here as well there are 30 planes
arriving here today the Moroccan fa have
given out 500 extra ticket so they'll
certainly outnumber France inside the
stadium this evening and who knows it
will be an amazing story if they can do
it but to do so they've got to get past
France and Killian mbappe joint top
scorer in this tournament is on track to
win the Golden Ball along with with
Lionel Messi so yeah it's going to be
difficult for them tonight but they've
surprised us all throughout this
tournament and who knows they might just
be able to do it again to set up a World
Cup final against Argentina which would
really be something wouldn't it it
certainly would Tim many thanks enjoy
the football
on today's Sky News Daily podcast uh
Sally Lockwood filling in for me is
joined by Dr NASA Muhammad himself gay
and katani but who now lives in the
United States he says that LGBT plus
guitaries feel removed from the
conversation about qatar's hosting of
the football World Cup you can listen
And subscribe for free whenever you get
your podcast I just scan that called on
your screen
no something for you to check out this
little guy's dribbling skills the
international Committee of the Red Cross
shared this video of two sang Ong after
receiving a new prosthetic leg at a
rehabilitation center in Myanmar
and he's got some skills although he's
going to get done for traveling there I
tell you he will be shooting Hoops in no
time
well done that we man now with a major
incident declared in shetlands after
thousands of homes were left without
power I'll be speaking the Island's
Police Chief Inspector that's next
foreign
[Music]
as we've been reporting a major incident
has been declared for Shetland after
thousands of homes were left without
power following heavy snow which brought
down power lines uh police say we're
join now on the program by The Police
Chief Inspector at father Shetland Isles
Stuart Clements and Stewart great to
have you on and I suspect that you are a
very very busy man right now so we will
try not to take up too much of your time
but just bring us up to date with the
very latest I mean to what extent has
has power been restored on the island
good morning Keith yeah thanks very much
for your time it's been a challenging um
48 Hours here on the island and power
has been has been a challenge for
obvious reasons with initially three
thousand eight hundred and customers of
Supply mainly the North End of the
island and through the work that SEC the
local electricity board I've been doing
have managed to bring that down to 1 800
but it's still a real challenge for the
residents who are actually still here
and still living in that area
are you managing to get the kind of the
technical staff that you need to get to
get the power back on onto Shetland
itself
yeah from up from my from the
electricity sec's um point of view
they've had that phenomenal response
um they've got 45 Engineers heading up
to Ireland to arrive this morning off
the boat along with 17 vehicles that
will complement the teams that they've
already got here taking them up to 60
engineers and their reports from our
meetings were having yesterday about
whom that has been catastrophic to use a
better word and they've never seen in 30
years Devastation of overhead power
lines and it's been a really finely
balanced set of environment
environmental kind of conditions that
have seen at the the ice and the snow
start performing the top of the
electricity islands and then those
pylons then actually and taking the
weight and accidentally went down to the
ground but it's really working a
highlighting the work on going in the
background the impact of the snow has
been definitely unprecedented our local
resilience Partnerships have set up
they've been working really tirelessly
over the last in 24 40 hours right
through the night to make sure that
ultimately we're caring for the people
and our vulnerable people in the
community
I mean I've been shared with a couple of
times myself and it can be wild at the
best of times just describe to us what
the weather was like when it was it was
at its peak
yeah I think it's first of all it's good
to see that actually the the community
are shared under a hearty Bunch
they're really good
um living through all and we've
certainly got a win in a yellow wind
warning later on today for between 50
and 60 miles an hour that's under normal
circumstance is a great kind of standard
practice up here but impact it was
already the power outages and
um the snow that's been on the ground
that's what's going here all night long
we're expecting for our snow road
closures and drifting this morning
um so so tell me just a little bit
Stuart about the calls that you and your
colleagues will be receiving right now
because uh you know as I understand it
if you you'll still be able to use the
999 ability on your on your mobile phone
even if the even if the landlines are
down so what are people looking for what
assistance are people requiring
two seconds it's um
the
um some of the phone lines have um had
challenges over the last kind of 24 48
Hours British Telecom were working
really hard to restore them and some of
the final outages that we have
um are linked to the power outages once
the power comes back on that'll come
back up but yeah we're we're um they are
just the people to ultimately stay at
home stay safe look after the friends
the families their colleagues anybody
that possibly can round about them all
um to um
excuse me
the phone's going to get on the
background apologies if you need to take
this dude oh it's okay no it's okay yeah
so um a challenge in 48 hours looking
for people to stay at home the capital
of friends look after the families and
um just really have that good neighbor
that Community feeling that they
actually have across state across the
island and it's very very strong here
are you local to Shetland yourself or
have you ended up there with uh with
work I'm just wondering just so you can
maybe just tell us a little bit about
the islands in in better times because I
have to say it is one of those places
that that people always sell I'm going
to try and visit but they don't and they
really should maybe not right now yeah
thank you no Absolutely I'll finish it
on now for yeah um I'm predominantly
from the west of Scotland
yeah yeah yeah the Glasgow reaction
comes through slightly
um but no it's an absolute absolutely
stunning place to live and to work and
the community I've been so open so
welcoming to me even I've come here as
well
um under normal circumstances absolutely
we're not despite probably popular
belief we don't tend to get cold
temperatures we don't tend to get high
temperatures we tend to care around
about that average and I saw a good
summer's day here 16 17 degrees but
likewise in the winter the temperatures
don't drop to maybe some of the
temperatures we're seeing in bremar ETC
at the moment down to -17 last night we
very really get innocent lower than kind
of minus one minus two here in German
and just a word from you as well Stuart
about your colleagues and within police
Scotland but also the the other
Emergency Services who will be working
Round the Clock I suspect in Shetland I
mean they they must be putting in the
graph they must be putting in the hours
right now
yeah a big big thank you to all the
emergency Partners who have come around
the table over the last 14 hours and the
Coast Guard
um have been phenomenal they were
deploying yesterday we had a couple of
ongoing incidents into the point 17
staff along with the four or four by
four vehicles to help us ambulance fire
brigade all the Emergency Services have
really come together the council as well
over 30 Critters out on the road
um this morning and yesterday as well
just clearing those vehicles that have
become trapped in the snow looking out
for the vulnerable people who may be
stranded into Vehicles Etc Earth teams
have been out in their four by fours
over the course of the day yesterday
last night and right through today and
again responded to any course where we
need it's looking out now for those
vulnerable people to make sure that
people have got the medical supplies
that they need the oxygen the insulin
Etc and so I was working in partnership
with the Health Board here in Ireland
we're helping to um be out there and
deliver those needs and goods we have
I will look at wishing you and all your
colleagues on Shetland all the best over
the next few days as you continue to
work hard Chief Inspector Stuart
Clementon thanks very much indeed
hey thank you very much
quick look at the weather
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon is sponsored by Qatar Airways
and it's looking to stay cold into the
weekend with a raw wind in the Northeast
and southwest bringing some sleet and
snow with it there'll be an extensive
sharp Frost at first like today with
some dense freezing fog patches over at
Central Parks wintry showers and yeah
many Northeastern coasts just a little
rain sleet and snow clearing from the
southwest most places will have a dry
and sunny morning but the fog will
linger in places
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
no have you ever wondered what it sounds
like all the way up there on Mars take a
listen
[Music]
sounds like the messages I leave my
parents on their answer phone when I
accidentally bum dial them but uh NASA
has actually just released this sound it
was captured by the perseverance Rover
last year now that crackling that
hissing that you can hear well that is
believed to be dust screens hitting the
Rover from a whirlwind you know these
so-called dust devil sounds uh
strikingly similar to Whirlwind here on
Earth but it is slightly quieter due to
Mars thin atmosphere
at much more coming up in the next I'll
be speaking to the shadow attorney
general Emily Thornbury about those
inflation figures
[Music]